you definitely don't need to be a
lumberjack to be next door anybody can
do it all shapes and sizes men women all
of you but my name is Matt Wilson we're
at battle the backyard ax our league or
the Toronto West located battle is a
community based around the activity of
expert what is ax right it's exactly
that it's it's throwing an axe at a
target for points standard match format
is three rounds of five throws per round
and you have to win two out of three
rounds to win that match it started with
me learning how to throw an axe that
cottage there's a whole lot of force up
here that's sort of how the initial idea
started and then this it was super
addictive this is like the culmination
of many years of debauchery and boredom
straight up like I threw an axe and it's
fun and we went from there this is one
of eight locations in Ontario and we
have one in Alberta as well we
definitely didn't invent the activity we
just invented a different way to do it
that I think works a little better in
heavily populated areas would I have
started if I didn't live in Canada I
don't know I think Toronto it's a pretty
world-class City that's that's open to
trying new things and taking on some new
adventures and and so people were very
open-minded to it I find a lot of people
in the city of Toronto that share values
and ideals with myself and it was in
battle we try and operate with a sense
of fairness and acceptance and equality
across the board we're already talking
to people overseas people in Australia
: in England let alone the states I
think the sport can be huge
[Music]